I first went there in 1984 when I was 22
and not an ink apologist I was a
philosopher and I have been going back
every year for at least a month
sometimes four so that's that's the 2009
so it's for 25 years and and the whole
you know the whole generations and
do you go strictly to work or is it I
mean is it for pleasure as well this
point I mean yeah yeah I mean I do
critical theory I'm very much you know
conceptual kind of person the work in
Australia as well as work with queer
communities in the US or kind of
ethnographic basis of my writing and
thinking but but their theory of
knowledge and obligation is now in me so
why do I go back to do work no just work
come out of it yes
do we have projects we do yes do I read
books from it yes but why do I go back
well I go back because you're now
obligated with each other am I ever
gonna not go back like I don't know I
guess how old I going back I have no
idea how do you break an obligation like
that so yes I go back to go back to go
back one of the great things about being
and teaching undergraduates is that they
are not you right and their world is not
the world's not my world in any way and
I don't want it to be my world actually
so and and what I like is that encounter
so the whole question of how does
someone
who's me who's this dense effect of a
whole set of experiences that have a
have a Templar mark to it kind of
generational mark you know how do I talk
to them I don't make whatever I'm
teaching compelling and it's very
interesting it's a very dialogical even
in lectures in which you're saying
something watching to see if it hits and
then asking them like okay you tell me
what is it
XYZ so does anything particular surprise
me no
but do they bore me no because they're
like this other thing and it makes makes
my work alive